bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment est-ce que
vous expliquer cette situation
en pleine pandémie toujours
on l'expliqué simplement par le fait qu'
on n'est pas changer de paradigme et que
la crise sanitaire alors que nous y
sommes encore dedans n'est pas servi
n'est pas été le détonateur
nécessaires à la prise de conscience des
politiques d'austérité qui ont été
menées depuis maintenant plusieurs
années puisque un état il ya eu 27 mille
suppressions de lits et depuis leur
prise de
fonction de monsieur président emmanuel
bach rome et bien ça n'a cessé de
continuer la preuve les chiffres le
reflète
nous avions vous l'avez dit un juin fait
une conférence de presse
avec des chiffres qui n'était pas
exhaustif on avait bien précisé puisque
nous sommes pas forcément implanté
partout dans toutes les structures et
nous était remonté environ 2000 aux
suppressions de lits vous n'y avait que
la crise sanitaire a même amplifié ces
fermetures de l'est de nombreuses
chambres doubles ont été transformés en
chambres simples pour limiter la
contagion épidémique et c'est cette
situation temporaire qui s'est pérennisé
c'est ça
oui bien sûr la cité se temporaire se
pérennise vous savez un lien direct de
toute façon entre les effectifs et puis
les capacités hospitalières l'offre de
soins et en plus de ça il y a eu le
virage ambulatoire qui n'a pas été
stoppée et qui ne correspond pas
forcément aux besoins de la population
qui je rappelle la population elle
augmente ah non et elle vieillit donc
l'ambulatoire n'est pas forcément adapté
dans toutes les situations et ça ne peut
pas être un palliatif à
l'hospitalisation complète ses
changements de stratégie avec un la
priorité donnée à l'ambulatoire il date
de quand
il tente maintenant de plusieurs années
voire de dizaines d'années mais ça n'a
cessé de s'accroître et comme ça ne
correspond pas à ce que aux besoins de
la population
notre fédération demande la réouverture
immédiate des lycans été fermé en exige
vraiment cette réouverture si on me
changer de paradigme et si on veut dire
tenir compte de ce qui s'est produit
pendant la crise a été à voyez on
parlait des stocks des protections
individuelles etc via l'offre de soins
c'est la même chose des lits de
réanimation il ne l'a pas assez alors on
a augmenté la capacité des lits de
réanimation de l'ordre d'à peu près 7
186 lit pendant la crise sanitaire sauf
que en même temps les lits de soins
critiques ont diminué pour autant voyez
cdc des vases communicants parce qu'en
face il faut y mettre du personnel donc
à la fois on demande la réouverture de
ces lits et de recrutement massif de
personnel on n'est pas quoi si davantage
d'hospitalisations à domicile ces modes
de prise en charge à domicile en anglais
en toi en ambulatoire l oms quelles
conséquences concrètement pour les
patients
alors tout dépend je ne suis pas médecin
mais je ne peux pas vous dire ce qui
relève quel type de prise en charge
ce que je sais c'est qu'en face il faut
des professionnels de santé est ce que
je sais c'est que des aides soignantes
des infirmiers il n'y en a pas
suffisamment un nombre formé sur le
marché du travail à l'heure actuelle est
d'ailleurs bon nombre d'établissements
nous dise si on souhaitait même les
recruter on ne les aurait pas parce
qu'ils ont pas présent donc développé de
l'ambulatoire c'est aussi pendant
considération les moyens dont nous
disposons
donc il faut renforcer à la fois en
termes de formation le nombre les
capacités des instituts de formation en
soins infirmiers et en personnel et de
soignants pour pouvoir peut-être
améliorer la situation mais en tout état
de cause l'hôpital doit tenir son rang
et l'hôpital vous savez quand on va à
l'hôpital on n'y va jamais de gaieté de
coeur donc quand on est hospitalisé on a
besoin d'avoir un lit immédiatement les
français savent aujourd'hui que cas ils
veulent dans certaines spécialités frein
donné rendez vous c'est très compliqué
c'est très long et ça ce n'est pas
forcément accessible
alors comment est ce que vous expliquer
ce manque de personnel et comment créer
aujourd'hui davantage
d'attractivité dans les hôpitaux
vous savez notre activité c'est
c'est multifactoriel
c'est à la fois les conditions de
travail c'est les taux d'incidence c'est
à dire les accidents de travail c'est
voilà l'amélioration des conditions de
travail passe par l'augmentation des
effectifs voilà les salaires on a signé
un premier accord je dirais dans le cas
d'un protocole d'accord du ségur sur les
carrières rémunération et je précise sur
les carrières rémunération pas sur leurs
fonds dessous et pas sur les capacités
repas sur le nombre de lits donc voilà
qui améliore un peu la situation pour
certains personnels mais pour d'autres
qui travaillent à l'hôpital on attend
encore fait le tour de la question dans
la mesure où il ya un bon nombre de
personnels comme pas été encore
revalorisés au niveau des grilles
indiciaires de rémunération donc il faut
continuer à travailler là dessus il faut
que le gouvernement prenne en compte
véritablement le besoin des hospitaliers
à la fois de reconnaissance et et de
mettre des moyens qu'il faut sur la
table pour qu'on puisse fonctionner
correctement ce n'est pas justement
l'objectif du secteur de la santé
et bien si mais vous savez le volet un
carrier rémunération c'est le protocole
d'accord que nous avons signé ensuite il
y avait le volet deux volets 3 le volet
4 c'est-à-dire la gouvernance l'offre de
souhaits etc etc il ya eu des débats il
y avait des préconisations des
recommandations mais à ce jour on ne
voit pas qu'elle soit suivie d'effet
voilà et même quand on voit et qu'on
s'arrête sur le nombre de sept milles 7
758 suppressions de lits à nonant ça
fait je dirais un petit peu froid dans
le dos on est particulièrement déçus en
demande un changement de paradigme
radical l'ouverture de discussions sur
ces thèmes précis et demande aux
français ce qu'ils souhaitent pour être
prise en charge correctement merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne gilles gadier je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
fédéral ait faute des services publics
et de santé